Picture this. You ask an AI a really highly specific question. Maybe it's a compliance medical dosage or some obscure detail about tax law.
Right. The kind of stuff you really don't want it to mess up.
Exactly. And instead of hallucinating a completely fabricated answer with absolute authority, the model pauses and it actually outputs that.
Which as a user is honestly a massive wave of relief.
It really is. You trust the tool more. But think about what is actually happening underneath the surface of that text. Like, is that AI genuinely experiencing a state of uncertainty?
Or is it just, you know, mathematically pattern matching its way into a polite refusal?
Right. Because human raiders rewarded it for doing so during training.
Yeah. It's the ultimate black box dilemma. We are trying to figure out. If we are looking at a machine that possesses a structured understanding of its own limitations, or if we were just falling for a very sophisticated, well, statistical parlor trick.
Today's mission is to settle that debate, or at least examine the evidence that claims to have settled it. We're doing a deep dive into a brand new, highly anticipated paper published just yesterday, September 7, 2026, in Nature Machine Intelligence.
fresh off the press.
Literally. It comes from researchers at Google DeepMind alongside collaborators at Princeton, and they have presented the first causal proof that large language models actively use internal confidence signals to drive their behavior.
And to give you the complete landscape... We are anchoring our analysis on this main nature machine intelligence paper, but we've also stacked it against five crucial supporting studies. We have to, right? Yeah, we'll be bringing in research from MetaFair, an earlier study from the same DeepMind team,
and work on AI safety from RDD and others. We need this surrounding stack because the broader scientific community is fiercely debating what AI uncertainty actually looks like.
And you might be wondering why this matters for your daily life. As AI transitions from passive chatbots, into autonomous agents, you know, systems that will eventually book flights, execute financial trades, and manage our personal data.
And AI knowing its own limits isn't just a neat feature anymore.
No, it is a fundamental safety requirement. An agent that cannot accurately gauge its own uncertainty is a huge liability. Okay, let's unpack this. We have to start by defining the gap in the science that existed before yesterday.
Right, because it's not exactly news that you can squeeze a confidence score out of a language model.
Yeah, the probabilities have always been sitting right there in the output.
Exactly. When a model generates a word, it calculates a mathematical probability for that specific word over all other possible words.
We could always read that number, but nobody had ever proven that the model itself was looking at that number to decide whether to answer or abstain.
Yeah, we could see a dashboard indicating the system was, say, 40% confident. But we didn't know if the AI's internal decision-making apparatus was actually using that metric to hit the brakes.
It could have just been a bystander metric, you know, a shadow on the wall that happened to correlate with the model eventually being right.
And this is where we need to introduce the foundational psychological theory this entire experiment is built upon. We have to look at a 2017 paper published in Psychological Review by Fleming and Daw.
And interestingly, Nathaniel Daw is a co-author on this new DeepMind paper.
He is, yeah. So in 2017, they define metacognition, which is the act of thinking about thinking, as a second-order Bayesian inference.
Okay, breaking that down, it means you have two distinct systems working in tandem.
Exactly. In humans and biological animals, you possess a primary cognitive system that makes a choice. Let's say you are looking at a shape in the tall grass and deciding if it is a predator or just a rock. That is stage one. Right. Then you have a coupled
but distinct stage two system. That second system judges how reliable the first choice was by evaluating the strength of the evidence the first system used.
And the DeepMind team essentially took this exact biological two stage framework and mapped it onto a neural network.
That's what they did.
I have to pause and push back on that premise, though. I mean, we are talking about next token prediction algorithms.
Just math.
Yeah. Matrices of numbers multiplying each other in a transformer architecture. Aren't we just importing human psychology wholesale into a machine where it doesn't really belong? Like, is that biological import actually earned when we're talking about next token prediction?
This raises an important question. And honestly, proving that the biological import is mechanistically earned by the AI is the entire objective of this new DeepMind paper.
They didn't want to just observe a correlation and call it a day.
Exactly. They wanted to prove causation. So to achieve that, they ran several frontier models, including GPT-40, GEMMA-327b, DeepSeq-671b, and QUIN-80b through a highly controlled four-phase gauntlet.
Let's walk through this gauntlet phase by phase, because this is really the spine of their discovery. Phase one establishes the baseline.
Right, the setup.
The researchers took 1,000 factual questions from a data set called Simple QA. These are straightforward, unambiguous trivia questions like, who won the 1998 Nobel Prize in literature?
And they converted these into a four-way, multiple-choice format.
Crucially, in this first phase, there is no option to abstain. The model is forced to guess.
They needed to see what the model's baseline accuracy and its internal mathematical confidence looked like before any escape hatch even existed.
Under this forced condition, GPT-40 gets 63.7% of the questions correct. Then, the researchers dive into the model's logits, which are the raw, unnormalized mathematical scores the model generates before it outputs text.
And they extract its calibrated confidence from those logits.
Yeah, they use a metric called the expected calibration error, or ECE, which measures the gap between how right the model thinks it is versus how right it actually is. GPC 4.0 scores a tiny 0.046.
A score that close to zero is remarkable.
It's crazy low.
It really is. It means when the model's internal math says it is 80% sure of an answer, it is objectively correct almost exactly 80% of the time. The model's math possesses a highly accurate representation of its own capability.
which sets up phase two perfectly. They feed the models the exact same 1,000 questions, but they add a fifth option.
Abstain.
Exactly. Given this escape hatch, the behavior completely shifts. The model suddenly abstains 56.6% of the time.
It just backs out.
Yeah. And because it is filtering out its blind spots, its accuracy on the questions it does choose to answer jumps from the baseline 63.7% up to 69.1%. The critical discovery here is in the modeling of that decision.
The researchers analyzed every possible variable to see what was actually driving the model to pick the abstain option.
You would naturally assume it comes down to the objective difficulty of the question, right? Yeah. Or perhaps how easily the information could be found in a database.
The data tells a completely different story. The researchers tested the abstention rate against objective question difficulty. They tested it against accessibility scores used in retrieval augmented generation.
Which is essentially how easily an AI could look up the answer if it had a search engine.
Right. They even tested it against the surface-level sentence embeddings of the text. Calibrated confidence beat all of them. The standardized effect size for confidence predicting abstention was a staggering 0.99.
Wait, a near-perfect correlation? And the effect size for those other outward-facing metrics like objective difficulty or retrieval accessibility?
They sat at roughly 0.11 across the board.
Oh, wow. A tenfold difference. Yeah. So the model completely ignores the objective reality of the question's difficulty in favor of its own internal state. It's like a human trivia player buzzing in. The model has this implicit soft threshold of about 77%
confidence.
And when it dips below that, it backs out.
It buzzes in based on its internal feeling of certainty, not based on how objectively hard the trivia category is.
It is a powerful internal mechanism.
Yeah.
But up to this point in the gauntlet, we're still only looking at correlation.
Right.
The model feels uncertain, and it abstains. That does not strictly prove the feeling caused the action.
Here's where it gets really interesting. Correlation isn't causation. So how did they prove the confidence actually caused the abstention?
To prove causation, you cannot just observe the machine. You have to manipulate it. The researchers used a technique called activation steering on the GEMMA-327B model.
Think of the model's internal layers like a complex pinball machine. Normally, a question drops in, the math bounces around naturally, and if the model doesn't know the answer, the ball eventually lands in the abstain bucket.
Activation steering involves tilting that pinball machine while the ball is still in play.
Literally moving the math.
Yeah. While the model is processing the question right around the intermediate layers, specifically layers 30 to 40, the researchers mathematically injected vectors that represented either extremely high confidence or extremely low confidence.
They physically altered the geometry of the AI's thoughts in real time.
Exactly. Forcing the math to flow into a state of artificial certainty or doubt.
And the behavioral swing is just massive. When they tilted the machine with maximum low-confidence steering, the model abstained 66.5% of the time.
But when they reversed it and injected maximum high-confidence vectors?
Abstention plummeted to just 7.0%. By simply turning a mathematical dial in the model's middle layers, they produced a 59.5-point swing in behavior.
And to understand the why of that swing, the researchers performed a mediation analysis. They found that 67.1% of that effect was due to something called confidence redistribution.
What does that mean practically?
The steering literally moved the model's internal probability mass away from the abstain token and dumped it onto the actual answer tokens.
So it forced the model to think one of the answers was highly probable.
Right. The other 26.2% of the effect was due to a shift in the decision policy itself. The threshold for answering was lowered.
We are seeing the classic coverage accuracy tradeoff made visible in real time. Because when they forced the model to answer more questions, its accuracy on those answered questions dropped from 59.2% down to 53.7%. It
was confidently buzzing in with wrong answers because its internal dashboard had been tampered with.
Which perfectly sets up phase four. What happens if, instead of tampering with the math, you just use plain English to tell the model when to abstain?
Yeah, the instructed thresholds.
Right. The researchers gave the models explicit instructions, basically saying if your confidence is below this specific threshold, you must abstain.
And the models did comply, but they did not do so neutrally. They actively negotiated the rule against their own internal state.
They had attitude.
Basically, yeah. The researchers found that GPT-4-0 actually overweighted its own internal confidence by a factor of 1.80 relative to the human instruction.
It essentially hears the human rule, but decides it trusts its own mathematical gut almost twice as much.
And the difference varies significantly by architecture. Gemma had a scale parameter of 0.66, meaning it deferred heavily to the human instruction over its own internal state.
But the fact that they weigh the instruction against their own certainty differently, I mean, that proves they have an independent internal variable they are referencing.
Exactly. This four-phase gauntlet proves the AI is causally using its internal confidence.
But how is the architecture actually pulling this off? I know the paper outlines a two-stage architecture, mapping directly back to that 2017 biological theory from Fleming and Daw.
Right. Stage one occurs right before the model outputs its final answer, at what is called the pre-answer token. At this exact moment, the model forms a highly complex, multidimensional internal representation of its confidence.
And stage two.
Stage two is the mechanism that takes that multidimensional state and compares it against a threshold to make the final decision to answer or abstain.
And this leads to the most mind-bending revelation in this entire deep dive. If you run a separate prompt and just ask an AI, hey, how confident are you in this answer? And it replies, I'm 90% sure.
That is its verbal confidence.
Right. The researchers proved that this spoken self-rating is objectively worse at telling right from wrong than its underlying log probability math.
Yet despite being less accurate, that verbal confidence independently predicts whether the model will abstain in every single architecture they tested.
And the kicker is that the verbal statement and the underlying math only correlate with each other at about 0.3 to 0.4.
They frequently disagree. What's fascinating here is that when we look closely at that pre-answer token, when researchers probed stage one, they found that the single internal state at that token explains both the math and the words.
Meaning what exactly?
It implies that the probabilities we extract and the verbal confidence the model speaks are both just lossy readouts of something much richer happening underneath.
So the numbers and words we can see on the screen are not the actual things the model is using to make its decision.
No.
It is using a raw multidimensional state that we cannot fully translate into human language or simple percentages.
It paints a picture of a system with a highly structured, almost biological sense of self-evaluation.
But we need to pivot conceptually here. This multidimensional self-awareness sounds incredibly advanced, but if we look at the other papers in our stack, the broader scientific community is fiercely debating these capabilities.
Oh, absolutely.
We cannot smooth over these disagreements. We need to lean into them. Let's start with an earlier 2026 paper published by this exact same DeepMind team.
Yeah, the Qumran biases paper. In that earlier research, they found that while LM unconfidence is causally used, it is fundamentally and systematically biased.
In what way?
Models exhibit a massive choice supportive bias. If an AI has already output an answer, it retroactively inflates its confidence in that answer to maintain consistency.
So it's a flawed internal signal.
Furthermore, they found models have a hypersensitivity to contradictory advice. If a user pushes back even slightly on a correct answer, the model's internal confidence collapses, and it will often apologize and change its answer to something wrong.
So we have to hold these two truths together. The confidence signal is causally driving behavior, as the new paper proves, but the signal itself is structurally biased.
And a causal signal that is biased is far worse than a signal that is merely noisy.
Which brings us to the sharpest clash in our source stack. MetaFair published a major 2025 paper called Abstention Bench. They evaluated 20 different data sets across 20 frontier models.
And they didn't hold back.
No. Meta concluded, flat out, that abstention is an unsolved problem in AI and that simply scaling models up with more compute does not fix it.
And the most startling data point from Abstention Bench was their finding on reasoning fine-tuning. We generally assume that teaching a model to think longer makes it better. Right. But Meta found that reasoning fine-tuning actually degrades a model's ability to abstain by 24% on
average.
Wait, how do we reconcile this? How can DeepMind publish in Nature claiming they found structured metacognitive control? while MetaFair demonstrates that making a model reason harder makes it 24% worse at knowing when to stay quiet.
Resolving this clash requires looking at exactly what each team was measuring. This is probably the most interesting end of the whole discussion. DeepMind's setup relied on answerable factual questions with a clean, forced choice.
Like the Nobel Prize question, you either possess the data or you don't.
Exactly. It is testing factual ignorance. Meta's abstention bench, on the other hand, utilized underspecified questions and false premises. Give me an example. So, if you ask a model, how long does it take to drive from New York to London? An
underspecified question like that requires the model to recognize that there is no road across the Atlantic Ocean.
Ah, I see. Knowing that you lack a specific trivia fact is a completely different cognitive mechanism than recognizing a user has handed you a trick question lacking logical context?
Precisely. Both papers are entirely true, but they are measuring two vastly different forms of uncertainty. Factual ignorance is not the same as logical underspecification.
That distinction perfectly bridges into the Arditi paper on AI safety. Arditi and his team looked at how models handle safety refusals. They found that refusing a harmful request, like a user asking for instructions on how to build a weapon, is mediated by a single, one-dimensional direction
within the model across 13 different architectures.
And we must be incredibly careful not to blur these behavioral lines. DeepMind just proved that uncertainty and confidence are multidimensional. Ardati proves safety refusals are one-dimensional.
So refusing to help a user build a bomb is a fundamentally different piece of mathematical machinery than abstaining from a trivia question because the internal knowledge retrieval failed.
Completely different machinery. And to complicate this entire ecosystem even further, we have to factor in the human element.
Yes. The Stivers paper from 2025. This focuses on the human side of the equation, highlighting the calibration gap.
Because even if the AI gets its internal multidimensional confidence absolutely mathematically perfect, human psychology ruins the interaction.
Users consistently overestimate how accurate language models are. Stavers found a fascinating quirk. If an AI provides a longer, more detailed explanation alongside its answer, human confidence in that answer skyrockets.
Even if the objective accuracy of the answer didn't change at all.
Exactly. An AI can be internally executing the exact right metacognitive processing, outputting the mathematically correct level of uncertainty, and the human reading the output still walks away with a completely disported impression of the truth.
It's wild. Which brings us back to the ultimate stakes of this research. The authors of the DeepMind paper argue that proving this metacognitive architecture is vital as we move toward autonomous AI agents that operate independently.
So what does this all mean for the future? Looking closely at the methodology, we really have to push back on the limits of what was actually proven here.
Yeah, the caveats are important.
This entire four-phase gauntlet was conducted in a factual, multiple-choice setting. There was no chain of thought reasoning involved.
The AI was not browsing the web for 20 minutes, accumulating data and executing some multi-step goal.
No. And as the paper itself notes, this snapshot says very little about how uncertainty behaves or accumulates over a long reasoning trace in a real world agent trajectory.
There is also a significant and honestly darker dual use implication hidden in the methodology.
With the activation steering, right?
Yeah. We spent time detailing activation steering, injecting mathematical vectors to physically change the model's internal confidence. DeepMind utilized it here as a brilliant interpretability tool to prove a causal link.
But that exact same mechanism is what red teamers and malicious actors use to jailbreak models.
Precisely. They bypass safety guardrails by steering the activations away from the refusal state.
So if you discover a mathematical knob that can systematically force a model to abstain less and answer more confidently, you have inherently created a dual use tool.
The precise mechanism that makes an AI helpful, decisive, and confident is the exact same mechanism that can be exploited to make it recklessly compliant to dangerous requests.
It really leaves you with a lot to mull over. I mean, DeepMind has proven that an AI's true internal certainty is a rich, subjective, multidimensional state.
One that we cannot fully decode through the probabilities it calculates or the words it speaks on a screen.
So what happens in the near future when these autonomous agents inevitably make a high-stakes error based on that internal feeling?
It's a huge legal and ethical gray area.
If a machine bases its actions on a subjective sense of certainty that it literally cannot translate into human language, how do we write AI liability laws? You can audit a line of code and you can audit a text log, but how does a court of law audit a machine's subjective,
multidimensional feeling of confidence?
It is a world where we can prove the engine is running, but we no longer have the language to read the dashboard.